ahora que hemos sido capaces de expresar
quién eres quién es de sigma en términos
de nuestros parámetros s&p creo que ya
estamos muy cerca de calcular la
integral misma esencialmente llegamos a
esto de calcular la norma de este
producto cruz y que es simplemente
después de bastante simplificaciones
llegamos a la raíz cuadrada del coseno
cuadrado de t que decíamos que es el
valor absoluto del coseno de t pero como
te lo estamos moviendo entre menos pi
medios y pi medios el coste no siempre
es positivo por lo cual no es necesario
ponerle ya los valores absolutos
entonces con esto dicho vamos a calcular
nuestra entre nuestra integral original
que es la integral sobre nuestra
superficie sigma de la función x
cuadrada de sigma ok entonces lo que
vamos a hacer entonces es expresar a x
en términos de nuestros parámetros y
aquí tenemos de sigma también tenemos
que convertir a x en términos de los
parámetros y eso está dado aquí en
nuestra parametrización de la superficie
ya que esta es la coordenada digamos x
entonces vamos a resumir esto a que x x
de ese combate es igual al coseno dt que
lo tenía yo con este color coseno de t
por el coseno ds por el coseno de f
coseno de ese entonces si sustituimos
este valor de x sobre la integral y
también sustituimos este valor de de
sigma lo que vamos a tener con x
cuadrada pues será simplemente coseno
cuadrado de t por el coseno cuadrado
coseno cuadrado de s ok y ahora si
multiplicamos por x de sigma esto sería
coseno dt de s
dt y esto hay que integrarlo entonces en
la región donde estén definidos los
parámetros que si retomamos aquí ese era
el ángulo de rotación en el plano xy por
lo tanto iba entre 0 y 2 p y t era
digamos el ángulo de elevación o que
tanto digamos bueno elevación hacia
arriba o hacia abajo baja respecto al
plano xy y por lo tanto éste sólo se
movía entre menos y medios y pi medios
así que ese se mueve entre 0 y 2 p y t
se mueve entre menos pi medios y para
medios muy bien esta es la integral que
hay que calcular esto esencialmente
podemos simplificarlo porque aquí
tenemos un coseno dt y un coseno
cuadrado desde entonces esto será igual
a la integral sobre la región de los
parámetros a digamos baja del coseno
cuadrado por coseno dt escocés al cubo
de t por el coseno cuadrado de s
con seno cuadrado de s y aquí vamos a
ponerlo de s dt muy bien entonces si nos
damos cuenta primero vamos a integrar
respecto de ese entonces como la primera
integral es respecto de s el coseno al
cubo de t esencialmente es una constante
se puede salir de esa integral ok
entonces vamos a tener lo siguiente
vamos a tener
la integral la integral de menos pi
medios y medios de quien del coseno al
cubo que se sale de esta integral es
decir este se sale de esta primera
integral y entonces tendremos coseno al
cubo de t por la integral
voy a hacerlo ahora con azul por la
integral de 0 a 2 pi que era la segunda
integral que teníamos del coseno
cuadrado de ese coseno cuadrado de ese
de s
y luego tenemos que terminar nuestra
integral entonces integramos respecto de
t muy bien entonces si nos damos cuenta
esto de aquí ya es una constante la
integral de una función es una constante
por lo tanto se puede salir también de
ésta de esta integral amarilla grandota
que tenemos entonces esto nos conduce a
que esto es igual a calcular la integral
de menos pi medios
apyme dios
del coseno al cubo coseno al cubo de t
dt por por la integral de 0 a 2 pi del
coseno cuadrado coseno cuadrado de s de
ese perfecto entonces lo que tenemos
ahora que hacer para resolver estas
integrales es sacar del baúl todas las
identidades trigonométricas que
conocemos para poder simplificar esto
por ejemplo por ejemplo vamos a empezar
con este de aquí de la izquierda quienes
coseno al cubo de t bueno podremos
primero factorizar un coseno de t
entonces esto lo podemos expresar como
coseno de t por el coseno cuadrado de t
ok
ahora bien quién es coseno cuadrado de t
bueno como sabemos que cose no hice no
cumplen que están en el círculo unitario
esto esto de aquí lo podemos expresar
como coseno de t por y este coseno
cuadrado lo podemos expresar como uno
menos el seno cuadrado dt muy bien
entonces si nosotros ahora usamos la
distribución de este producto tendremos
coseno de t
menos coseno de t seno cuadrado de t
perfecto y uno podría pensar oye pues
como que esta expresión es mucho más
complicada que esta de acá arriba y
tienen razón se ve más más esta
descabellada verdad pero en realidad
esto es más fácil porque podemos
encontrar una primitiva directamente de
es una una anti derivada ok vamos a
expresar el otro la otra parte esta de
aquí de otra forma por ejemplo podemos
expresar lo el coseno cuadrado siempre
lo podemos expresar como 1
más un medio por el coseno de 2 s muy
bien entonces esto esto esencialmente es
como nos vamos nos va a permitir
calcular de forma más sencilla y vamos a
ver que esto es así porque entonces
tendremos la integral la integral de
menos pi medios y medios de quien del
coseno dt coseno dt
- coseno dt seno cuadrado de t y aquí a
lo mejor para los que ya son muy buenos
integrando verán que en realidad el
coseno dt es la derivada del seno de t
por lo cual se antoja muchísimo utilizar
un cambio de variable luego vamos a
multiplicar por la integral de 0 a 2 y
de un medio un medio más un medio coseno
de 2 s todo esto respecto a s
ok perfecto entonces vamos a ver a que
nos ha que nos lleva esto esto vamos a
integrar lo vamos a encontrar una anti
derivada cual es la anti derivada del
coseno dt pues simplemente es seno de t
y ahora si hacemos un cambio de variable
digamos que uno sea seno de la
diferencial de v es la derivada del seno
que es coseno que está justamente
justamente aquí por la diferencial de t
por lo tanto esto simplemente es la
integral de o cuadrada porque es el seno
de t entonces podemos podemos verlo como
nuestra variable si integramos un
cuadrado lo que nos queda es o al cubo
entre 3 entonces tendremos menos uno al
cubo que es seno entonces es seno al
cubo de t sobre tres muy bien y todo
esto vamos a evaluarlo de menos y medios
y medios
vámonos con la siguiente parte la
siguiente parte
vamos a multiplicar por una una anti
derivada de un medio pues simplemente
será un medio porte por perdón no
exporte sports s por s
más como integramos un medio del coseno
de 12 s bueno fíjense que si tenemos la
integral la integral del coseno de 2 s
de ese entonces nos gustaría tener aquí
un 2
vamos a necesitar un 2 para poder hacer
el cambio de variable verdad hacemos
igual a 2s y la diferencial de v es dos
veces la diferencial de s pero no lo
tenemos entonces lo podemos agregar
siempre y cuando aquí afuera de la
integral se lo quitemos al dividir
nuevamente entre dos entonces ahora si
la integral de esto es directa porque
nos queda nos queda un medio nos queda
un medio de la integral de esta parte
que es el seno de 2 s entonces aquí bien
vamos a tener un medio de la integral
del coseno de 2 s que es un medio de
seno de 12 ese entonces un medio con
este un medio se hace un cuarto
seno de 2 s y todo esto evaluado de 0 a
2 y muy bien
muy bien entonces vamos a ver qué es lo
que nos da
a seguir evaluando en los límites y
primero vámonos con esto esta expresión
evaluado en pi medios quienes senodep y
medios senodep y medios pues es uno y si
le restamos el seno de pi medios al cubo
pues senodep y medios quedamos que era 1
al cubo seguir haciendo 1 y si dividimos
entre 3 será un tercio muy bien ahora
vamos a restar vamos a restar esta
expresión cuando evaluamos en menos y
medios entonces seno de menos pi medios
es menos uno verdad es movernos en
dirección de las manecillas del reloj
entonces esto será menos uno y aquí
vamos a él el seno
el seno al cubo de menos y medios es
menos 1 entre 3 pero con este menos se
hace más así que vamos a tener más
un tercio
muy bien entonces aquí lo que tenemos es
uno menos un tercio son dos tercios dos
tercios y aquí tenemos menos uno más un
tercio es menos dos tercios que con este
menos se vuelven más entonces tenemos
otros dos tercios que al final lo que
nos dan son cuatro tercios muy bien
ahora calculamos esta integral vámonos
de este lado un medio de ese evaluado en
dos pi pues simplemente será dos pie
entre dos que es pi
más
un cuarto por el seno de 2 s pero el
seno de 2 s como ese es 2 pi tendremos
seno de 4 pi y el seno de cualquier
múltiplo entero de pi es 0 por lo tanto
aquí ya no hay nada ok entonces este más
ya no va y hay que restar esto cuando lo
evaluamos en 0 pero cuando ese 0 esto se
vuelve 0 y seno de 0 es cero por lo
tanto no hubo que evaluar nada más ya
encontramos la integral porque
simplemente resulta de multiplicar estos
dos verdad esto resulta de multiplicar
estos dos que son cuatro tercios y pi
entonces esta integral de acá arriba
fíjense todo lo que ya hemos hecho para
llegar a ella esta integral de acá
arriba al final se resumió a 4 pi
tercios ese es el valor de esta integral
lo cual es muy bonito logramos calcular
esta integral de superficie después de
mucho esfuerzo yo creo que ahora sí nos
merecemos un rico descanso